bonsoir à tous air vous a fait deux fois
le jingle parce que on aime bien le
jingle sur figure life bienvenue dans le
grand studio du figaro on est en direct
on est avec vous ses filles or alive et
on attend vos points de vue l'europe
peut-elle se permettre d'accueillir une
nouvelle vague migratoire dossier à lire
dans le figaro ces prochaines heures en
pleine crise dans l'enclavé espagnole de
ceuta on en débat ce soir avec vous et
avec sophie de menthon bonsoir sophie
une chef d'entreprise et présidente
d'ethic est avec nous avec vous comme à
chaque fois adrien matou bonsoir à driss
harassant journaliste à marianne et
auteur d'un livre très intéressant à
lire en ce moment mêlant chant la chute
jeudi en ce moment puisque la polémique
rebondit on va y revenir peut-être avec
jean luc mélenchon mais également sous
un autre aspect avec une question une
polémique soulevée par le syndicat
alliance
est ce que le problème de la police
c'est vraiment la justice
eh bien on attend vos réponses et on va
en débattre
mais d'abord la situation était plutôt
calme ce matin dans l'enclavé espagnole
de ceuta reste que depuis le début de la
semaine ce sont plusieurs milliers de
candidats à l'immigration un afflux sans
précédent qui ont rejoint donc le club
espagnol
ils ont profité d'un relâchement des
contrôles frontaliers côté marocain sur
fond de crise diplomatique majeure entre
madrid et rabat alors je vous la fait
courte qu'elle est le le point de litige
entre l'espagne et le maroc c'est que
l'espagne a accueilli sur son sol
le leader d'un mouvement indépendantisme
d'un vieux mouvement indépendantiste le
front polisario qui milite pour
l'indépendance du sahara occidental donc
c'est la partie sud du maroc avant d'en
débattre
je vous propose d'écouter d'abord ce
qu'en pense la commissaire européenne
il va johansson et puis on écoutera
également le président socialiste du
gouvernement espagnol pedro sanchez
et des rings d'haddad lise 6 tarzan
people&baby number of the children
swimming tous et autant pour tim daly
findel mennea to be rescued water slide
2007 morocco continuent de commettre de
pleuven gilad est produit en date dos tu
ta tunique de right now de leanne
effectively alors la commissaire
européenne à 1 parle de 6000 candidats à
l'immigration et maintenant ce sont 8000
personnes qui sont arrivées sur sur
l'enclavé de ceuta dans le club de ceuta
la réponse européenne qu'on vient
d'entendre
elle avait été réclamée précédemment par
le président socialiste du gouvernement
espagnol pedro sanchez je vous proposais
l'écouter raconter la falc avec contrôle
nous avons espagne sophie vous approuvez
la réponse heureux 2 millions européenne
et du gouvernement espagnol cette
réponse qui demanda au maroc de vraiment
de refermer ses frontières alors il faut
quand même être clair on paie pour
qu'ils gardent les futurs émigrés on
paie des pays avoisinants
ils ont et sont vengés
et ils ont laissé passer des gens pour
pour laissant passer les migrants pour
se venger
donc il ya le maroc aussi parce que on a
eu un accord avec la turquie où il paye
6 milliards d'euros à bp tout le monde
d'une façon ou d'une auto peu tout le
monde
on paie tout le monde pour qu'ils
gardent leurs immigrés je pense pas que
ce soit une situation stable à la limite
payer pour garder les émigrés soit mais
si au moins cet argent servait à éduquer
les gens et servait à ces pays mais pas
du tout ça enrichit plutôt des
dictateurs et donc on donne de l'argent
des dictateurs pour qu'ils gardent des
gens pour qu'ils envahissent pas c'est
atrocement malsain comme système
donc il n'ya pas de réponse c'est pas
une demande de réponse là il va falloir
trouver plus en plus on pourra pas payer
indéfiniment voilà 2-6 6-1 dictateur
pendant le roi mohamed6 un dictateur non
priori aimerais tu sais tu pas dictateur
mais faciles sont des priorités sa
compagne est mort il n'est pas d'en tuer
lui c'est pas des démocraties on voit
très bien quand on va s'installer à
maroc ce qui m'est arrivé là en
angleterre est pas élu non plus et
pourtant c'est une démocratie ne va pas
comparer à 2 tient pas le pouvoir
pouvoir être comparé elle n'a pas de
pouvoir n a aucun pouvoir elle est enfin
bon les violations démocratique on va
faire la sultane aux auditeurs de leur
expliquer que c'est pas pareil quand
même la reine d'angleterre et mohamed
cissé le roi du maroc
d'accord mais quand même il ya deux
élections libres au maroc
oui mais je veux dire y'a il ya des
rapports par exemple au maroc vous
arrivez à saluer une boîte ça a été mon
cas j'y suis allé on voit un nombre de
gens il faut payer vous savez pas quoi
mais il faut payer pour vous installer
faut des autorisations et ses principes
par un pays
démocratique comme on l'entend en europe
que ce soit je critique pas régiment il
veut un régime qui est pas plus mal que
certains autres enfin en attendant on
est en train de payer à nos frontières
alors ça veut dire une chose d'abord ça
veut dire que marine le pen a raison en
disant qu'il faut des frontières forte
ça n'a rien à voir il faut de l'argent
pour payer pour avoir des frontières et
elle existe malheureusement pas de la
façon dont on voudrait mais ça veut dire
quoi fermer les frontières on peut pas
faire autre chose que ce qu'on fait et
où là je suis très inquiète il va y
avoir un réchauffement climatique
donc qu'est-ce qu'on va faire je je je
oui ça me cherche il disait que faire de
la politique c'était essayer de résoudre
des problèmes absolument est soluble
c'est le cas j'ai pas de solution alors
est ce que c'est le cas vraiment adria
votre point de vue et est ce que l
inverse on peut venir que justement la
réponse de bruxelles et de madrid
moi ce qui m'a frappé c'est la fermeté
de la réponse la déclaration est-ce que
c'est pas le signe qu'en matière
d'immigration en revanche rien est
inéluctable quand on veut refuser on
peut pas ça peut être étonnant de la
part de l'europe ceci dit ça fait
plusieurs années que loeb est
particulièrement ferme et que je crois
que c'est la zone dans le monde rejette
le plus de monde à la frontière alors
sur la question de l'immigration plus de
mérite plus que oui puisque les états
unis me semble mais oui alors en tout
cas je pense que ce qui est essentiel
dans le débat sur l'immigration c'est de
différencier les formes d'immigration
parce que en fait sinon c'est quand même
très très floue de dirhams migration
migrants immigrés ya plusieurs formes
d'immigration
l'immigration familiale et les étudiants
qui viennent utiliser il ya
l'immigration économique et il ya les
réfugiés qui fuient les zones de la
guerre par exemple ou alors ils étaient
nourris ce que la mort je trouve que ce
ne serait pas sérieux
enfin plus que parce que ce serait une
faute grave de renoncer à l'asile qui
est un droit fondamental
quand quelqu'un est en danger de mort
dans un endroit il doit pouvoir être
accueillis ailleurs ce qui pose problème
il va y avoir réchauffement climatique
parce que ce sera aussi à l'angle jeu
pour l'instant la gym ça que je lui m
laissons cette question de côté - elle
est complexe mais en tout cas il me
semble que c'est que ces ressortissants
marocains ne
souffre pas a priori ne sont pas en
danger de mort dans leur pays
alors on pourrait penser après le oui
c'est ça pour être légitime à certaines
périodes que on peut accueillir des
immigrés économiques en grand nombre et
c'est je pense qu'actuellement
en tout cas je parle pour la france je
pense que l'espagne c'est relativement
similaires les sociétés européennes sont
sous pression pression économique parce
qu'on connaît le rôle du dumping et
notamment avec les travailleurs immigrés
pression culturelle cresson sociale je
pense que une grande majorité de
français et peut-être pas d'espagnoles
d'ailleurs mais en tout cas en france je
sais que c'est le cas sont d'accord pour
mettre une pause sur l'immigration pour
réduire les flux et à mon avis par
exemple si on veut nombreux dans le
placenta
à mon avis si on veut préserver si on
veut préserver l'asile qui met toujours
existé il faut un petit peut réduire les
autres formes de flux et là la question
se pose et je le laisse ouverts parce
qu'ils viennent manger pas la réponse
est ce que la réponse doit être
européenne
ou est-ce que la réponse votre française
les européens
certes sont plus efficaces si ce corps
donne ceci dit la gestion des immigrés
est un désastre en europe parce que la
moitié des pays d'europe notamment de
l'est refusent d'accueillir le moindre
mix que je vous pose des versements
l'émigration peut venir de l'est
européen alors attrapé a donc il faut
aussi gérer ça c'est ce que montre
patrick stefanini notamment dans son
dernier livre en expliquant que la
majeure partie de l'immigration clients
en allemagne notamment et une
immigration intragroupe exactement et
cette immigration intra européennes ce
qui est inquiétant c'est que c'est une
migration dont on a besoin j'ai déjà
parlé je crois de cette patron de
l'entreprise de car qui va chercher 30
chauffeurs deux fois par an dans les
pays de l'est
il n'y a pas un français qui veut te
faire d'écart alors on en a je rédigeais
4 on en a pas besoin
les patrons s'en servent pour faire des
et les salaires entre pas mais elle n'a
pas baissé mais c'est là toute façon
c'est le missile est justement si les
salaires étaient plus élevés je suis sûr
que vous trouveriez cetc évidente et ce
sont les allemands de la question des
salaires élevés pu remonter salaires
plus il ya de chômage que si tu savais
que rapport quand vous payez 1500 balle
ça vous en a coûté 2007 donc
très compliqué moi je demande pas mieux
donner les 2007 un salarié plutôt que
1000 c'est sain c'est pas mal calé vous
dites dans la relation entre le salaire
et le chômage n'est pas absolument
mécanique c'est plus complexe que ça
mais je veux quand même insisté sur ce
fait l'immigration spécialement
l'émulation entre à européenne parce que
là ça sonne un cadre légal a toujours
été soutenue par le patronat parce
qu'elle lui permettait 2 si vous pouvez
pas regarder les vignobles quand vous
faites les vendanges par exemple à des
saisonniers qui se sont payé hier ça
mais il ya en france à qui voudrait le
faire si c'était à des conditions
acceptables faudrait que acceptable
elles sont acceptables pour beaucoup de
gens sont acceptables pour l'île grande
n'a pas d'autre choix
c'est ça c'est ça la gamescom pour
l'accordéon vous avez plein de
clandestins ont regardé ils arrivent ici
des pays de l'est s'ils sont émerveillés
alors on leur donne leur droit ils sont
déclarés c'est pas du tout des
clandestins émerveillé l'émerveillé bah
oui on aura beau ils sont énervés riz
mais c'est quand même maintenant si au
niveau de l'europe on n'a même pas
d'égalité on le sait très bien on est
attendu il faut mais c'est pas les gens
qui vont s'aligner sur la france
ça va être compliqué puisqu'on parle de
l'europe justement au delà de la crise
des migrants de ceuta et c'est l'objet
donc dû du dossier du figaro à lire
demain premiers articles sont sortis des
interviews de commissaire européen et
il ya une crainte en tous les cas on
voit en europe est nouvelle mais magre
vagues migratoires
cette fois ci qui venus de tunisie et de
libye
je prends pas encore de turquie mais il
ya un indicateur selon le haut
commissariat aux réfugiés
les départs depuis la libye ont
nettement augmenté depuis le début de
l'année avec 11000 départ de janvier à
avril à 2021 ses 73 % de plus qu'à la
même période l'an passé notamment et sec
intéressant en raison de la
détérioration de la situation pour les
étrangers notamment en libye qu'est ce
que veut faire l'union européenne et de
pays européens par rapport à mai déjà
j'aimerais bien savoir le nombre de
personnes que ça représente
il parle de 11000 départ 11000 départ
alors voilà les parents alors alors déjà
il faut faire la différence entre les
gens mais là je pense que pour lequel la
libye la majorité des gens qui partent
c'est pas de l'immigration économique ou
familial c'est des gens qui ont vraiment
en danger en ligne et vu la situation en
libye si on y réfléchit et si on est
raisonnable onze mille personnes à
l'échelle de l'europe c'est quand même
pas grand chose c'est quand même pas
grand chose l'europe à l'échelle de
l'europe où et quand même pour le coup
je trouve que même à l'échelle de la
france c'est limité mais je dis pas que
la france doit prendre en compte les
onze mille libyens
en théorie moi qui ne suis pas un
européiste fanatiques je serais quand
même pas choqué que les pays d'europe se
mettent d'accord pour se répartir les
11000 personnes c'est pas énorme
et voilà en fait on en revient à la
condition faite aux trois conditions qui
font que l'immigration est acceptable
pour les pour les pays d'accueil faut
qu'elles soient régulés faut que les
flux soient pas trop importants afin que
les émigrés soit en minorité dans le
pays d'accueil et qui s'offre une
majorité faut qu'elle soit bien la
partie n'était pas en soi est d'accord
avec ce produit à l'échelle de leurs
convergences inattendues à l'échelle de
l'europe
très attendu il faut qu'elles soient
répartis à l'échelle de l'europe mais
également à l'intérieur du pays par
exemple en france vous regardez les
données de francs stratégie et les
endroits où il n'y a pas un seul immigré
des endroits où la majorité des gens
sont issus de l'immigration et la
troisième condition c'est que les
immigrés devaient être assimilés
il faut des voix la liste ps à la
culture d'accueil moi je pense que les
trois problèmes sont importants et est
important est en fait la simulation peut
être réussie que si les deux premières
conditions sont réunies en théorie sur
ses flux de 11000 personnes
on pourrait très bien y arriver si les
pays se mettaient d'accord
volonté commune or elle n'existe pas il
ya quand même un problème avec les pays
de l'est je suis désolé qu'ils ne
veulent absolument accueillir pas la
moindre personne à vivre même comprends
je savais qu'il n'arrive pas c'est quand
même des raisons qui ne veulent plus des
immigrés alors traversé c'est un
problème parce que je crois 100% mais en
france soit 360 c'est qu'on n'arrive pas
à gérer qu'on en a beaucoup trop 75% des
français si c'est ça je suis d'accord
mais en fait je conteste pas ce constat
mais je pense qu'en france par exemple
la france porte un poids considérable
dans l'immigration en europe c'est le
pays où je pense qu'il ya c'est un des
pays où il ya le plus de gens immigrés
ou d'origine immigrée en europe et les
pays qui n'ont pas un seul
ceci dit vous n'avez pas les forcer à
vous n'allez pas les forcer à prendre à
prendre c'est ça le problème il faut
respecter la souveraineté nationale des
pays et donc c'est là qu'on a un
problème et que ce problème est un petit
peu irrésoluble surtout que c'est peut
être un autre sujet qu'on pourrait
lancer la france peut être contrainte
par l'europe d'accepter des gens encore
plus ou moins contrainte puisque les
autres acceptaient pas parce que bas
parce que par exemple la cod h sous la
cour de justice européenne vont vous
empêcher de renvoyer dans leur pays
quelqu'un qui est déboutée du droit
d'asile en invoquant des grands
principes comme par exemple je crois le
ya le droit à vivre le droit à la vie en
famille qui est un grand principe de la
cour de justice européenne et qui peut
être invoquée par exemple alors que le
regroupement familial
voilà un problème majeur qui a été une
véritable catastrophe et et qui est
qu'il faudrait arrêter immédiatement le
plus grand regret de valéry giscard
d'estaing
oui enfin emmanuel macron on a rajouté
mais puisque le regroupement familial il
a rajouté les frères et soeurs
sympathique certes l'europe peut-elle se
permettre d'accueillir une nouvelle
vague migratoire c'est la question qu'on
me pose sur twitter vous répondez non en
majorité je vous donne la parole et je
salue par la même occasion notamment au
large
nicole ou général et skype audit
internautes récurrents
je vous préviens d'ailleurs sur youtube
général est ce qu'elle va falloir venir
nous voir directement sur le site du
figaro parce que bientôt nous ne
diffuserons plus en direct sur youtube
vous pourrez voir les replays l'une des
choses en plus en direct mais sur le
site du figaro toujours et partout on ne
peut plus se permettre d'absorber toute
cette immigration nous dit cet
internaute sans compter tous les
problèmes qui est génèral ap
l'europe ne peut plus permettre une
nouvelle vague migratoire sous peine de
disparaître
nicole je ne comprends pas pourquoi on
nous dit qu'on ne peut pas avoir une
immigration choisie alors que ça existe
ailleurs
d'abord en europe d'ailleurs notamment
dans quel pays donc je vous prendre un
exemple où c'est la gauche qui est au
pouvoir c'est le danemark
ces intérêts sont d'ailleurs c'est un
article du figaro donc je vous conseille
que répressive aux sources le danemark à
une politique extrêmement restrictive en
matière d'immigration le les conditions
de naturalisation ont été vraiment
restreinte
il incite les réfugiés qui sont venus en
2015 et dont les zones de départ sont
maintenant sûrs à revenir dans leur pays
d'origine et ils veulent également alors
ça ça va être compliqué mais ils veulent
installer les centres d'accueil et de
tri des demandeurs d'asile dans des pays
tiers par exemple au rwanda la scène on
a un exemple où vous avez un
gouvernement de gauche qui a une
politique extrêmement fermes sur le plan
migratoire du système de hotspots
finalement et qui voit là et qui le fait
dans une ration choisi où on est obligé
dans des régions je pense en vendée où
on a des médecins qui arrivent
régulièrement de pologne etc
on apporte des médecins donc si on
augmentait apple numéro 2 clausus on a
ça ça me parait h 20
je peux passer par le sas et c'est en
cours ça l'immigration effectivement
l'immigration de l'union européenne est
un mensonge nous dit général escape les
migrants vont que dans deux tiers des
pays aidant ces pays ils s'entassent que
dans une dizaine de grandes villes c'est
ce que vous serviez tout à l'heure adria
et donc
le maître un jeter un coup d'oeil pardon
à la question qu'on posait sur twitter
doha peut-elle se permettre d'accueillir
une nouvelle vague migratoire et vous
répondez non à 73% été nombreux à voter
l'autre question qu'on vous pose
elle est sur twitter mais surtout sur le
site du figaro faut-il instaurer des
peines plancher pour les agressions de
policiers c'est donc la question qu'on
pose depuis la mi journée et là vous
répondez oui à tout moment sur le site
du figaro à une très très large majorité
quasi neuf 9 internautes sur 10
en attendant d'en débattre je vous
propose
de revenir sur deux séquences qui font
polémique d'abord ce happening du
syndicat alliance hier lors de la
manifestation de soutien à la police où
on voit
donc ça policiers mais en fait qui est
déguisé en délinquant aux capuches et
qui vient de tirer sur des policiers qui
sont tombés par terre et en blanc des
personnes qui représente le personnel
judiciaire et qui balayent ces morts est
derrière vous avez encore le délinquant
qui tirent sur les policiers et les
personnels judiciaires qui repasse un
coup de balai ça fait polémique c'est un
une mise en scène et une vidéo du
syndicat alliance l'autre polémiquer
mais assez la déclaration hier à la
tribune du secrétaire général du
syndicat on écoute et on y revient juste
après
les magistrats rendent la justice au nom
du peuple français
il serait grand temps qu ils la rendent
au bénéfice du peuple français
il faut être clair alors soyons clairs
le problème de la police c'est la
justice
et voici l inverse le point de vue du
ministre de la justice hier à
l'assemblée ce qui me semble en revanche
dangereux pour notre démocratie c'est
que l'on oppose en permanence la justice
et la police les policiers les
magistrats de son de ce pays sont dans
la même barque républicaine mais ne
posez pas s'il vous plaît deux grandes
institutions de la république
sophie de menthon c'est pas un peu
excessif de dire que le problème de la
police la justice et aussi les moyens
non oui c'est les moyens alors les
moyens d'abord toute façon ça fait des
années puis tout ça en france de quelque
chose qui va pas dit que c'est les
moyens
ces rappels à l'issue favorable à ce
qu'on les augmente les moyens de la
police je suis d'accord je suis des
prisons pour qu'on privatise la
construction des prisons
je suis pour absolument qu'on fasse des
maisons ce qu'on appelle de correction
de redressement ce qui est très mal vu
peut-être mais les mineurs on ne sait
pas quoi faire des mineurs et c'est
dramatique ça dramatique
alors ça c'est évident et c'est pas la
faute
effectivement de la justice d'un autre
côté la justice elle sait pas quoi faire
des mineurs donc effectivement n'est pas
efficace toutefois je crois qu'il y a
une véritable nécessité à ce que on ne
puisse pas toucher un cheveu d'un flic
je veux dire c'est dire brutalement mais
c'est pas possible je lisais un
reportage d'une d'une femme qui était
policier qui était ni un incendie dans
un square qui s'est fait quasi cassé le
poignet par un parent un délinquant il a
eu un rappel à l'ordre
et ça on ne peut pas accepter ça dans ce
pays donc c'est vraiment trop difficiles
et puis il y a parce que tous malliard
la culture de l'excusé où on a quand
même très tendance aujourd'hui en france
a trouvé des excuses et pourquoi pas je
pense que
c'est aussi important d'analyser les
pourquoi des agressions mais la culture
de l'excusé extraordinaire enfin je veux
dire c'est quand même celui qui est
agressé qui doit prouver qu'il l'est et
que l'agresseur on a une quand même une
grande grande indulgence donc les peines
de prison ne sont pas effectués vous
pouvez le demander aux policiers etc
voulez vous envoyer au code se faire
juger imaginons qu'il ya une panne elle
est très légère
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un rappel à
l'ordre enfin si c'est juste pas
possible et c'est valable pour les
femmes battues
les sommes qu'on laisse effectivement
qui ont soit disant un bracelet mais
qu'on suit pas donc oui il y a un
problème de la justice qui est rendue
derrière moi j'ai pas aimé j'ai gardé
cette espèce de civilité de la justice
envers six politique du sis de classe
etc
tu penses aux murs des cons j'ai
vraiment pas digéré ce que vous y étiez
manon non la chance parce qu'il est
gamin le journaliste du figaro qui était
notamment ivan rioufol et yves thréard
mais bon en tout cas ça vous l'avez oui
pas tolérable il faudrait un peu de bon
sens si juste pas tolérable ok un
problème de justice je comprends le
garde des sceaux qui l'aï les mâles et
bailly pas à l'aise je pense que darmana
à tout à fait bien fait d'aller aux
côtés de ses hommes
parce que c'est c'est pas les plantes ou
qu'ils soient un autre mais c'est que
oui il sait que yann on va revoir
peut-être revenir sur derrière madame on
a déjà eu le débat sur la place de
darmana au côté des policiers
georges donc justement sur ces sources
cette déclaration le problème de justice
le problème de la police et la justice
en tout cas on a bien compris votre
votre point de vue et 10 livrables m et
c'est vrai qu adrien d'un autre côté
quand on entend qu'un homme qui asperge
d'essence des policiers à tourcoing et
qui tentent de leur mettre le feu des
coptes que de sursis ou un simple stage
de citoyenneté pour quelqu'un qui lance
un cocktail molotov sur des crs
11 il ya un problème alors on dit qu'il
ya un problème est effectivement si
c'est le cas il ya un problème alors je
me permettrai quand même d'être un petit
peu méfiants parce que c'est le patron
d'allianz je crois qu'il ya 6 tc exemple
seule une manifestation pour avoir
regardé de près quelques exemples
de kaki la cité évidemment il ne connaît
pas le dossier
et souvent quand on sentit intéresse de
près vous savez en justice on peut être
attaquée pour plusieurs
on peut être inculpé pour plusieurs
causes différentes et en fait par
exemple pour le cas du policier qui a
été brûlé et bien souvent là je le
qualifiant je sais pas mais souvent
quand on regarde ce que dit le patron
d'allianz
c'est quelqu'un qui a été condamné pour
un autre délit il a été innocenté ou
alors il ya eu un non lieu pour ceux des
lilas et du coup la peine paraît
ridicule par rapport à l'accusation de
base donc voilà je pense qu'il faut
quand même regarder
il est vrai que quand on n'est pas dans
nos biens se vendent police au doigt
quand même est un tout petit peu
emphatique
alors après on aimerait bien savoir à
combien enfin à combien était en fait je
voulais justement non mais je voulais en
parler parce que les juges alors on peut
critiquer les juges mais lors leurs
interprètes ou bien alors oui leur
interprétation est limité
les textes de loi c'est vrai les délais
des lits où les crimes sont punis par
des peines qui sont prévues à cet effet
vous pouvez pas dire quelqu'un a cramé
un policier a voulu mettre un rappel à
l'ordre qui n'existe pas à ça c'est il
n'y a pas eu assez de preuve peut-être
pendant l' enquête pour pouvoir dire que
la personne était coupable de ce délit
l'a donc la peine paraît faible par
rapport à ce qui a été
ce qui était mis sur la table au départ
j'ai en fait je veux pas apparaître
comme quelqu'un qui dit y a aucun
problème
je suis un petit peu mal à l'aise avec
cette commande ya cette police qui met
quand même sous pression les magistrats
pour réaliser un petit peu ce qu'ils
pensent être des factieux en faisant ça
en disant ça je n'aime pas le terme
factieux mais je pense que honnêtement
je pense que là pour le coup le
gouvernement doit vraiment ne pas être
faible et que les policiers n'ont pas à
mettre sous pression les magistrats et
enfin moi je pense que si maintenant il
est de mettre nos malades parce que les
bêtes sous pression leur mettre devant
leurs responsabilités
pour moi c'était la même chose ce que je
veux dire en tout cas c'est qu'il faut
une nouvelle loi parce que ça c'est pas
dans l'arsenal juridique
on ne touchera pas les policiers pascal
ac pas les juges qui sont sous pression
c'est vrai que les juges appliquent la
loi c'est pour ça que parce qu'on dit
c'est scandaleux c'était devant
l'assemblée et
darmana s'il peut pas faire passer ça il
est normal devant la serbe est
d'ailleurs je sais pas ce que fait
l'assemblée parce que l'assemblée avait
jugé bon de sortir dehors avec les
policiers que ce soit de droite ou de
gauche parce que voyons d'où vient le
vent et c'était plutôt populaire hier
dire qu'on ne sentait pas menacée on
était tranquille à la manifestation
mais je vous le dis j'ai bah oui c'était
mon quartier donc j'ai un peu c'est de
repérer un petit peu fait du repérage et
non mais vous pouviez la même prix
qu'aux d'ailleurs maintenant mais il se
trouve que j'ai raté si nos chalets
parce que je pense que là les policiers
c'est trop dur pour eux c'est en
permanence les voix qu'il faut quand
même pas oublier les voitures qui
brûlent vous avez 40 voitures qui
brûlent tous les week-ends et c'est les
mecs qui peuvent pas présente pas à
pénétrer dans les banlieues même les
pompiers ne peuvent pas il y en a un
problème majeur
alors on est en train de discutailler
effectivement du fait que mais non c'est
pas de la photo c'est pas la faute de
quelqu'un elle c'est un système qui ne
va plus il est passionné l'air doit pas
toucher aux syndicats le syndicat
alliance clairement si vous en dit pas
le faire alors pour prise de position
demande une forme d'impunité des
policiers et mettre la pression sur les
juges mais mais oui oui mais je suis
d'accord avec vous sur le fait qu'il
doit y avoir une peine lourde est
applicable tour sur personne qui
s'attaque avec elle à quelqu'un qui est
dépositaire de l'autorité alors on va y
revenir
ça va y revenir et juste je cite tête ou
qui nous dit il faut surtout arrêter
cette mascarade qui consiste à arrêter
des délinquants pour toutes sortes de
mets fait qu'ils sont relais chez oc -
près mais nos prisons sont saturés et
nos tribunaux débordés oui parce qu'il
n'ya pas aussi là le problème il ya un
vainqueur du mans et puis l'autre
problème on parlait de la nature des
peines un gros effectif
mais ces problèmes c'est l'exécution des
peines alors ça j'allais vous en parlez
l'application des peines est un grand
problème
ceci dit et je m'excuse par avance
auprès de sophie il ya un point de
moyens c'est 1h30 prison et mobiliseront
façon ici la ligne c des moyens pour
leur gardien oui absolument taylorien
pour le régler en 10 mille détenus en
france 60 km une place de prison et des
conditions de détention catastrophique
et c'est vrai que ceux traités au privé
peut-être et en plus parfois on peut se
demander est ce qu'elle est ce que
mettre un petit délinquant en prison
avec des grandes et grands délinquants
ccc une solution et ensuite sur la
justice parce que j'ai quelques chiffres
quand même pour vous il ya onze juges en
france pour cent mille habitants
la moyenne de l'europe c'est plus de
deux fois plus il ya trois procureurs en
france pour cent mille habitants en
europe ces 12 pour cent mille habitants
on a quand même chez nous on a ce qu'il
faut
papa l'administration judiciaire pour le
maxi la france investit 69 euros par
habitant pour le fonctionnement de la
justice
ces 131 euros en
en allemagne et 92 euros en espagne donc
on n'est quand même pas aux standards de
compression ce collectif sont un peu
débordées par la question on n'abordera
pas ce qu'il va se peut qu'une minute
mais c'est comment justement on accorde
plus de moyens aux régalien travailler
les policiers les parts de relie détenus
ils travaillent déjà
alors c'est je vous propose là on est là
alors on a un il ya deux questions qui
sont posées et je remets vous me le
rappeler on aborde sa mission dans un
autre dans un autre débat
je voudrais revenir sur l'autre question
parce que c'est la question qui est
posée sur le sur le site du figaro sur
twitter c'est sur les peines plancher
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de réactions de
la part des internautes qui sont
polarisées les peines planchers vous
êtes pour vous être contre ce four
adrien moi je suis plutôt pour après
j'en fais pas une solution miracle aux
aides ont déjà été mises en place c est
pourquoi est ce que vous croyez
justement la thèse qui dit par exemple
d'olivier fort qui dit on les a mis en
place mais ça n'a pas marché
bah c'est vrai que ça va pas être très
efficace elles ont été mises en place
pour le coup c'est une solution qui a
été testé à quoi vous attribuer cet
échec alors ben en fait bas notamment
par le feu la nature de ces plaines
plancher à c'était je restais à des
peines de prison pour certains délits
bano certains délits de massaro touché à
un flic c'est une idée tout de suite
mais les peines de planches et de mère
général le fait est que les statistiques
le montrent mettre en prison quelqu'un
pour un délit c'est pas très efficace du
haut niveau de la récidive c'est pas
quelque chose qui empêche pas de top
chef
alors le tournoi pendant son rôle court
terme mais vu qu'on peut pas emprisonner
tout le monde toute la vie après bien
passif quand même alors on reparlera
justement des moyens de la police
justice et des prisons parce que c'est
très intéressant fait tout ce qui est
soulevé kriss kross peu propose des
peines très ferme de cinq ans
incompressibles pour toutes agressions
anti flics vole pas eu alors attention
je vous ai vu à quel internaute qui
étaient choqués par l'emploi de termes
flic mai
et donc ils préfèrent le thème policiers
vole pas eu qui nous dit oui il faut des
peines planchers mais surtout bien
exécuté madame de stèles qui est une
internaute nous dit non tout simplement
parce que le principe de la peine
plancher est inconstitutionnelle et
contraire au principe
d'individualisation et perd des peines
quand on est condamné c'est soit qu'ils
aient condamné et pas en fonction d'un
seuil jeunesse alors c'est ça le c'est
l'autre l'autre débat et la justice
philippe et comme madame de staël douala
juste d'avoir une approche universaliste
et non pas une approche basée sur
l'individu même si alors ça aussi c'est
intéressant on n'a pas tellement le
temps d'en débattre mais c'est
intéressant de voir tout ce que ça ça
soulève il faut sanctionner dès le
premier dérapage nous dit chardons bleus
pour pas que justement les jeunes
continue à dériver c'est l'autre
politique c'est la question de la
tolérance zéro
j'ai juste une dernière question alors
la question va peut-être regarder les
réponses qui ont été faites sur les
peines planchers vous étiez quasiment 9
sur 10 au début de l'émission à être
favorables à cette instauration des
peines planchers et c'est toujours le
tas le cas quasiment quasiment neuf sur
dix 89 56 vous êtes plus de 30000 et
35000 à avoir voté vous pouvez continuer
à voter sur le site du figaro et sur
twitter par contre vous êtes un petit
peu moins 80% mais quand même une
écrasante majorité
votre point de vue adrien est ce que
mélenchon renforcer ou affaibli de cette
séquence il aurait pu sortir renforcés
signer n'avait pas dit que c'était une
manifestation factieuses leur courrier à
mon avis un excès de langage de sa part
mais le fait de ne pas participer me
scandalise pas du tout bon après voilà
qualifié de factieux un tel
rassemblement
c'était un petit peu maladroit 2 je
trouve de sa part parce que il se
renforcer au niveau d'un segment
électoral par exemple dans cette
séquence le fait de ne pas cadrer c'est
vrai qu'il ya un évolution générale des
insoumis qui ont longtemps été accusé
par toute une partie de la gauche
radicale d'être beaucoup trop pro flics
parce que c'était un petit peu la
culture républicaine jacobine de la
france insoumise et qui depuis la
perquisition de mélenchon et les jets
les jaunes ont adopté une rhétorique est
un petit peu anti flics mais qui pense
ne sera pas excessivement efficace
notamment pour la présidentielle parce
qu' elle ne peut que convenir un segment
limité de la population en réalité
est-ce que ça consolide le noyau
militants il mais est ce que c est ce
que ça consolide le noyau électoral
eh ben je vous dirais que la dichotomie
entre par le militant et parler aux
électeurs c'est un petit peu tout ce qui
plombe mélenchon depuis depuis deux ans
donc voilà donc je vous pose la question
différemment en clair est-ce que
mélenchon surfer c'est d'un point de vue
militant au sein du au sein de la gauche
radicale mais est ce que justement ça ne
l'affaiblît pas d'un point de vue
électoral
ouais bien sûr après je pense pas que ce
soit un épisode marquant non plus mais
mais oui ça ça participe de cette
dynamique qui est qui parle davantage
des mines
très politisé qu'à l'ensemble de la
population et voilà je pense pas que ça
tourne ça serait poudre si oui alors
dont vous les excuses et demandé une
expertise il a écrit un bouquin sur la
question on le recommande que ça n'avait
selon moi absolument aucune incidence
parce qu'il ya d'excellents livres qui
dit qu'il est mort mélenchon la chute
c'est mélenchon l'absolu c'est de ce
livre est qui est écrit par notre
excellent confrère adrian mathoux et qui
est aux éditions du rocher et qui est
vraiment passionnant et intéressant à
dire je vous recommande deux dernières
choses de dossiers donc sur les
migrations et l'europe face aux défis
migratoires
à lire dans les prochaines heures sur le
site du figaro et dans l'édition papier
du figaro daté de ce vendredi mais
disponible en pdf et pour les abonnés et
ça vaut le coup de sabot n'est pas ce
que c'est pas cher et vous en avez
vraiment pour votre argent sur le site
du figaro et puis vous avez également
demain le un dossier également sur la
polémique qui continuent autour dé la
colère des policiers on ouvre avec ça le
journal dans les prochaines heures
et puis vous aurez demain à 9 heures je
vous donne rendez vous à 11h pardon pour
un live questions réponses avec notre
jeune confrère paul sujet qui aident à
lire un livre justement sur le mouvement
animaliste qui s'appelle l'extinction de
l'homme pour l'interrogation aux
éditions tallandier qui est absolument
passionnant et il répondra à vos
questions que je transmettrai ministre a
tout seul dont le studio stream du
figaro merci beaucoup
sophie d'avoir été avec nous merci adria
et on se retrouve demain même heure même
endroit avec l'excellent guillaume
roquette et je vous recommande bien
entendu le nouveau numéro du figaro
magazine qui répond à toutes les
questions autour du que vide avec pas
mal de médecins qui prennent la parole
et qui interpelle olivier ferrand il
leur répond chacun point par point il ya
le docteur il ya à la fois blachier il
ya le docteur marty mais il ya également
le professeur peron didier raoul tu es
également et qui
interpelle donc le
olivier ferrand qui leur répondent et je
vous recommande également 2e
retrouvez sur le site du figaro ça vient
de tomber le nouveau sondage pour les
régionales dans les hauts de france qui
montre que pour l'instant xavier
bertrand consolide son avance dans le
haut de france c'est à retrouver donc
sur le site du figaro a très vite sur
fédéraux life
[Musique]